drei junge mädchen zwölf jahre alt erst
werden sexuell genötigt von einer ganze
menge an jugendlichen zwischen 12 und 17
jahren diese meldung kam in den
vergangenen tagen rein als ganz kleine
meldung in den lokalnachrichten dort in
bayern abgespielt hat sich dort in
diesem freibad dieser teilweise so klein
wie würden aufmerksam darauf wir haben
uns vorgenommen diesen fall nicht aus
den augen zu verlieren bild schaut hin
wir sind natürlich hingefahren und wir
konnten auch mit dem bademeister
sprechen
ich habe hier in der aufsicht auf dem
großen bildschirm das war ein
wasserbecken beobachtet und eine gruppe
jugendlicher gesehen die sich im wasser
etwas benommen haben und mir gedacht ein
andere gäste auch darum muss für ruhe
sorgen und darum bin ich richtung
warmwasserbecken gegangen da er sich
vorgekommen bin zum becken war diese
gruppe die ich vor im auge hatte eben um
diese mädchen herum gestanden mit
anderen badegästen auch und die hat so
ausgesehen als wenn sie bedrängt sich
bedrängt gefühlt haben und dann aber
eben die situation aufgelöst ich habe
gesagt war ob sie die mädchen kennen
haben sie das verneint oder sagt sie
sollen sich da schweigen und sind eben
dann rausgegangen und hier ins freibad
in hagen das becken gegangen haben sich
hier so etwas wie eine videoüberwachung
könnte dass sie dann mal schildern
können dass sie das auf den bildschirm
gesehen haben nein wir haben nur für
momentanen aufnahmen also wird nichts
aufgezeichnet das was wir hier sehen ist
der moment und danach ist es weg wird
nicht aufgezeichnet also es gibt kein
bildmaterial von der geschichte ja und
bei uns her zu unser bild reporter karl
keim aus kaufbeuren größter die carl du
hast gerade eben mit ihm sprechen können
die den tathergang dort noch mal
schildern lassen mir bleiben viele
fragezeichen im kopf es sind so viele
menschen drumherum im freibad die das
sehen es ist der bademeister der
einschreite der sozusagen ja ein kleiner
held in diesem moment ist so trotzdem
fehlt jede spur von diesen jugendlichen
man weiß nicht wo die sind wie man die
finden kann
ja jetzt scheint die situation ein
bisschen klar arzt zu sein denn im
gespräch mit dem bademeister mit seinen
kollegen ob man herausfinden können dass
diese jugendlichen dass diese gruppe von
jugendlichen schon häufiger gewesen ist
man kennt sie zwar nicht aber sind jetzt
hier schon öfters negativ aufgefallen
haben ja auch die bademeister auch schon
beleidigt verbal das war schon tage
wochen zuvor der fall aber jahren das
natürlich spannend warum tatsächlich
niemand anders da eingegriffen hat warum
erst der bademeister eingreifen musste
das sind doch ich würde sagen ich hab'
ich konnte mich da drinnen umschauen das
sind doch gute 50 meter unterschied bis
zu diesem warmwasserbecken und dem
bereich wo sich der bademeister auffällt
total irre in manchen augen ist dass das
nur überwacht wird von der videokamera
aber gar nicht aufgezeichnet wird wieder
einmal aus datenschutzgründen sonst
hätte man die tat sehr wahrscheinlich
einwandfrei dokumentieren können und
dann auch er jeweils den menschen dazu
ordnen können das sollte hat sich
nämlich auch viel unterwasser abgespielt
das bedeutet aber wenn man die
jugendlichen kennt die dort übergriffig
wurden und die mädchen belästigt haben
dann steht die polizei kurz davor diese
auch zu fassen ist das etwas was die
polizei die ja auch bestätigen kann
also ich gehe davon aus und auch hier
die bademeister gehen davon aus dass
heißt eigentlich nur noch eine kurze
zeit dauerte bis man diesen männern
daran hapert ist jugendlichen die ja
einen dunklen teint gehabt haben
gebrochen deutsch gesprochen haben ich
glaube schon dass man die ihr kennt auch
von anderweitigen schulen aber bis man
sie dann natürlich ganz genau ausfindig
macht wo sie wohnen und dann natürlich
man muss ja auch vernehmen da muss ein
anwalt dabei seien unter 14 jahren
strafunmündig also das spielen auch ein
paar organisatorische dinge eine rolle
aber ich denke mal das dürfte jetzt
jetzt nicht mehr allzu lange dauern bis
man diese jugendlichen gefunden hat man
spricht von einer gruppe hier von bis zu
56 menschen 56 jugendliche die
zwölfjährige mädchen dort anfassen im
mittenbereich in diesem freibad in
kaufbeuren was war da los das schildert
gerade unser bild reporter karl heim was
ist los aktuell in unseren freibädern
melden sie sich auch hierbei bild